and this is why tiger woods keeps
working this is why warren buffett keeps
working it's why richard branson keeps
working
the only way in which businesses or
people will become successful
and truly perform to their optimum this
amazing question
is probably the best question i've ever
been asked
[Music]
camille thank you for joining me today
it's a pleasure to have you here so
early in the morning i
i typically on this podcast will won't
introduce people because
um i i'll do a little bit of a
pre-introduction but your
your background and the work you've done
specifically with high performance
people and successful people
is so compelling and fascinating that i
feel like
i want you to introduce yourself and
i've read through your bio multiple
times
it was deeply inspiring and i think
without an introduction everything we
talk about from here
without the perfect introduction which i
feel like only you'll give
everything we talk about from here on um
might not have the
the context it needs to have so who is
jamil creation
i'm a performance coach and psychologist
so i've
spent my time working with some very
good sports teams some very good
business teams
some successful people and i guess what
i do is i help people cultivate a
mindset for success
so i always say that for us to act
differently we need to think differently
i'm going to create different behaviors
different actions this is about creating
different
thoughts first so i guess what i do more
than anything else is help people change
their mind
so i said there's new new opportunities
new possibilities that will come from
new perspectives
so a lot of my time is spent working
with people not to give them new skills
but more to allow them to understand the
skills that they've already got
and then create a perspective for them
to use it differently
so um as a performance coach i think
everyone can be better
everyone can perform better at terms as
a matter of i guess trying to create the
mindset the attitude um i guess some of
the precursors to those
to the performance which are which are
beneficiary which have benefit to them
and so you said that everybody has the
skills and i i you know
i i see that in a lot of my friends i
see that they have a lot more sort of um
natural capabilities than they've
managed to sort of give the world
through
their actions if someone has an ambition
to be something
if they have the ambition to be you know
a sports
uh star and you've worked with a lot of
athletes and you've worked with business
people or they want to start a business
what you tend to see it and what i tend
to see in my inbox is
a lot of people with intention but there
seems to be something preventing that
intention from turning into
action or like behavior into an
achievement yeah
yeah and i think you know turning
ambition into achievement
is the key because most people will have
good intentions most people will be
wishing and hoping to be better
there's a big difference between wishing
and hoping and believing and executing
upon it
so i think that the people who genuinely
execute on it
probably want it more for a start at a
monastic key no one's ever wandered
around the bottom of a mountain
and then simply found themselves at the
top and it does take that determination
the resilience it does take the ability
to
execute upon ideas to drive success
so i think the key is the desire which
is fueled by having a
purpose a mission a vision towards what
that end goal should look like
a lot of people um can't quite
they say one thing they say that their
their purpose is to
go to the gym yeah for example we all
say one thing and do the other
yeah and why is that like because it's
sometimes hard to distinguish with
someone
whether that's their real sort of desire
or whether they're kind of like
virtue signaling to themselves if they
want to be something
or you know they want to start that
business or become an entrepreneur be
you know get a six-pack but then their
actions show that
quite a different story so i always
wondered that with my some of my friends
always think are they
do they actually want that or they just
it's very easy
to say that this is what i'm after and
much harder to do it
and i think one of the reasons why is
because um we have to invest we
self-invest
so we probably all know these um kids at
school who are great footballers at 14
15. you think you know what they're
gonna make it they're just brilliant
they're gonna make it
um or great track athletes at 12 and you
know and you just think
they're special but they don't make it
and the reason why they don't make it is
they don't self-invest
so the people who make it are the ones
who
um will get up on a rainy friday morning
and rainy saturday morning to
go and practice whilst their mates are
in bed the ones who will
practice on a friday night when their
mates are out drinking
and so talent is not enough you need
talent plus teachability
so talent plus the ability to be
open-minded agile in our thinking
to commit to practice and turn that
practice into something which develops
our talent even further
so there's lots of people with talent
and business lots of people with talent
and sport
um but i guess that we need to be
open-minded enough to invest
in how we practice our talent to become
successful
so you know there's no there's no
substitute for practice i get lots of
golfers who say to me that yeah can you
make me better
yeah and yeah the number one golfer in
the world will practice
more than any any amateur you know and
you know their lies the truth
but you know we need to we need to apply
ourselves in a particular manner and so
we need to be practical about how we
exercise our talent
you create good feedback loops to
understand what we're doing
gain better personal introspection and
self-awareness
to allow us to use our talents
differently how do you give someone that
purpose though like i'm trying to think
like
so we know we know practice is like so
incredibly important to master something
but my
i guess my question is um how would you
give someone
that motivation because i i i guess
you can't give someone purpose a lot of
us spend so much of our lives trying to
to motivate people right
to motivate friends families you know
siblings whatever it might be
i'm wondering if there's a thing we can
do as like loving
friends or whatever to to give someone
that kick yeah so i mean a couple of
points i guess on that in regard to
discovering purpose
um it can't be done for someone so
i always said purpose is never achieved
it's attained on a daily basis
so the mistake that people make with
purpose is they confuse it with an end
goal
so here's my purpose and have this
vision statement of what they're seeking
to
you know achieve or create whatever it
might be and get practical and tangible
about it
but purpose isn't that purpose is
achieved on a daily basis that
um sorry purpose is never achieved it's
attained on a daily basis
and this is why tiger woods keeps
working this is why warren buffett keeps
working it's why richard branson keeps
working it's because it's
never achieved it's attained on a daily
basis so i think that you know
we need to find something which is
purposeful to us
um and then we need to lose ourselves to
it on a regular basis
so once we start to become more purpose
driven and express ourselves in a
particular way
obviously being a good colleague being a
good business leader been a good sports
person is not seeking to impress
it's about seeking to express and be
ourselves in the context of our work
so once people can find that um
within themselves um then i think they
can direct their energy and their focus
in a particular way
and become much more purpose driven in
how they go about their daily activities
but you can't give someone that purpose
it has to be theirs
and i think life is about timing i think
some people find that very late some
people find that very early
and um and it makes no difference we're
all individuals in regard to
helping other people make change we're
almost too
quick to go towards behaviors so we tell
people to be different all the time tell
our team members you should be more
collaborative guys
i don't guys need to be more innovative
and tell our children to
keep their rooms tidy so we're
constantly talking to people about
behaviors
say to our friends that you should give
up smoking or eat healthier whatever it
might be
the only way in which you change actions
is by changing thoughts
so we think and then we feel and then we
act that's how we work
so if you're constantly working on
actions we're telling people to be
different and this is why new year's
resolutions fail
from tomorrow i'll be different start
doing this i'm going to stop doing that
and we start talking about actions and
behaviors
um we need to go back to the um granted
a precursor of all our
actions which is our thoughts so the
only way in which you genuinely drive
commitment rather than compliance when
it comes to change in your team in your
friends you know and yourself
is by changing the words and pictures in
your head or their head to drive
different feelings and then different
actions there's um
a little tip which i sometimes give
leaders and so i said leaders never say
to your team you're gonna make a change
you say to your team you're gonna make a
change they won't like it um say to your
team
i'd like to try and experiment they'll
they'll be on board with it and um we'll
give that a go that's okay
so even just a difference in language to
allow someone to think differently or
make them feel differently and hopefully
therefore
choose to act in a different manner and
how how would i get someone to change
their thoughts
you know i think um i think the best way
is gamification
um what holds people in place is what
they believe to be true
and then so um so people will sit around
a boardroom table
and i'll discuss strategy and i'll say
you know look you know we can do this
but we can't do that
and they'll have a viewpoint on budgets
on consumer buying behaviors
on on compliance and governance and
that's what holds this in place
so what we need to do is break free of
some of the parameters that we think
are in the way so if we got people
around the boardroom table
and said look guys let's just this
strategy piece that we're going to talk
about let's imagine we got an unlimited
marketing budget for it
if we had an unlimited marketing budget
for it i know we haven't but if we had
what would we be doing how would we be
doing it um you know if we had no
marketing budget
what would we be doing now what we're
doing here is that we are helping people
to move outside of the mental tram lines
that we all operate under
and under habitual thinking so let's ask
some what if questions
can you imagine that you know a life if
you weren't smoking
i told what it looked like i don't know
what you'd be doing today if you weren't
smoking what'd you spend your money on
that you saved on cigarettes
just played the game of what if so let's
break free of some of the things which
are holding
people in place by um not by conflict
not by arguing and and debate in a
confrontational manner
but finding some common ground and
working from there and the common ground
is
let's play a game and you you said that
you know about
people finding that purpose um in their
lives you we hear this
uh phrase um a lot which is
find your passion yeah and i almost feel
that it's it's
in many respects quite harmful because
it that question is kind of loaded it it
assumes a singular passion for a star it
sounds that you can
discover it like an easter egg and then
and also
um the the context in which that
question usually sits in it implies that
once you find it
then it's you know then it's the the the
it's a can of unlimited like happiness
and
orientation forever and then that's
yours and it
i just feel like sometimes language can
be harmful because it
it simplifies very complex things and
sometimes multifaceted
plural things you know so i wondered if
that you know that phrase
uh find your per find your passion was
something you um
you felt similar about or yeah i do i
mean yeah it's true that passion can be
a
significant multiplier of human
potential
so you know if people are passionate and
engaged in a business
they can direct their energy in a in a
worthwhile meaningful manner
so so so it's it's worthwhile but you're
right and um that you know there's a big
difference between
passion big difference between happiness
and joy
um some are in the moment at home i
think joy is in the moment and
i think happiness is something um that
we continually continually
adjust towards um your passion can be a
significant multiplier of human
potential
particularly in the workplace so it does
have a
place it is something which is useful to
understand and then ultimately
it always comes down to personal
introspection and self-awareness for me
and i think that um we need to work
harder at understanding ourselves
and when we are constructing a mindset
which is conducive to performance
so we optimize our potential when we're
in a particular state of mind
and that state of mind might be passion
it might be relaxation
it might be enthusiasm might be
enjoyment but we need to almost get to
know ourselves
and know that um there are certain
things which enable us to do others
and once we work backwards and
understand what that looks like maybe we
can gain some more consistency
i say to a lot of sports people and to a
lot of business people that
consistency of mind gives you
consistency of play
and i'm convinced of it and the more
consistent we can be in our thinking
we understand um the building blocks the
component parts to success
yeah the more success we can have and
how does one establish consistency of
thought
because i completely agree with that i
completely agree i've seen that in my
own life when i've been
consistent with my thinking i've managed
to you know
perform the same habits every day um but
then sometimes
i'll lose consistency in my thoughts
because i lose um
[Music]
i lose i guess i lose attachment or sort
of my anchor with my my why
yeah and i talk a lot i've talked a lot
in this podcast over the last couple of
weeks about
this realization i've had this year with
the gym which was every year
february march i was incredibly
motivated to go
fired up trying to look good for summer
yeah
and then obviously once you look good
and summer has ended
it's almost like you've lost your anchor
right so you get into
september and the why which made you go
and to think consistently every day
has been is evaporated and i'm tr i
can't get myself to go to the gym in
october
right you look in great shape for it
this was the other
video i realized so this was the year i
realized that this is the year i booked
the trend for the first time in my life
because i realized that i thought to
myself every single year
i i do it for this period and then i
stop and
they're two different people august
steve and october steve don't know each
other they're like you know what i mean
they're like twins that were separated
at birth and so this was the year where
i realized what i was doing and why
i was losing my motivation so i thought
[ __ ] it you know i'm gonna anchor my why
to something a bit more uh long term
and without a timeline so i said to
myself listen i persuaded myself of all
the reasons
why i want to be healthy and view my
life as one season
and that's what's allowed me to
persevere and also i got a bit pissed
off with myself i thought
you're really like that like like
you're that vain and you're like you
know but so yeah do you know i mean i
always think that
consistency of mind comes from
understanding the intrinsic quality of
our decision-making processes
and i say that a lot to people in sport
and in business so
yeah you can make a good decision and
have a really bad outcome
you can make a bad decision have a good
outcome and this is why i've worked with
leadership teams who have confused luck
for genius
and really bad decisions with a great
outcome you know markets have changed
competition's done something something's
just worked in their favor
um so um so it's really important for us
to
not judge our decision making by our
outcomes
and we often do so we'll say this is a
good decision because it resulted in
this
or this is a bad decision it resulted in
that
and we can only understand the outcome
retrospectively
so it's wrong to measure our decisions
by the outcomes and
we need to go back to how we made a
decision in the first place and once we
start to understand the intrinsic
quality of our decision making process
we can become more consistent in how we
make decisions
and therefore have more control over
those outcomes so i think that you know
two things i don't i think that and then
we'll use you as the example here steve
um that consistency of mind will come
from knowing how we make decisions okay
i understand that we put
our weight into evidence how much we use
prejudice and bias and opinion whatever
it might be
but let's understand how we make
decisions and in that way we can be
consistent
in um how we apply our logic and
thinking and feeling
try and determine some best outcomes and
then the other thing and um
as you've just positioned is reframing
let's stand back and create some time
and space
to understand and um you know why we do
things and why we don't do things
now i always say that um the people are
most successful and i've had a pleasure
working with six sports people who got
to number one in the world
i can guarantee you one thing i had in
common was that
um um they um they never made big
changes
and um it was small changes so i'm a big
big believer in the one degree of change
if you take two parallel lines and you
move one by one degree it may not seem
much at first
but it's a really big difference between
where you start and where you end up
so um everyone's trying to you know make
a dramatic change and see change from
tomorrow i'm going to be different
i think it's about doing something a
little bit more than what we've been
doing it matan a bit more consistently
and then the other thing with these
people who obtained you know what i call
um super achievements at home so they
did really really well
um is that they actually worked on their
strengths they started to understand
what was good about them
and do that some more so we think to be
better
as human beings i'm gonna be better as a
business or a team of people we need to
fix our weaknesses
um i'm not sure that's true i actually
think it's more about understanding our
strengths and playing to them
so um i've actually worked with teams
before in business and in sport
who have actually weakened the strength
by trying to strengthen a weakness
if you think about it it's ridiculous
and actually weaken the strength by
trying to strengthen the weakness we
need to be careful
so i think understanding what's good
about us understanding you know
where our behaviors come from in regard
to the thinking before it
and then reframing some of those words
and pictures and i guess that's what
you've done with your gym
example because i guess change some of
the words and pictures in your head
to therefore feel differently which has
resulted you and acting differently
yeah and i really you know i was i was
valuing intensity over consistency and
intensity wasn't sustainable right so i
was going through the summer like
to the gym two times a day i was
starving myself like eating things that
i
i didn't want to necessarily eat yeah
and the the consistency came from being
a bit more um
realistic with myself being yeah you
know if you missed the day of gym it
doesn't matter you don't have to
perspective
yes perspective isn't it yeah and i
think do you know it's funny because
again
something so many sports people have
worked with and business people who
will lose perspective they'll lose the
tournament and it's dreadful you know
win a tournament i've made it you know
this is it this is
turning point for me now they win a big
contract you know in business
and you know this is us now we're set up
you know or they lose a contract
and um and life has never been so
dreadful um but i think that we need a
better perspective on things so their
ability to think more long term
term to be more forgiving you know to
understand with more
um reality at uh what's good and what's
not so good
is probably the way forwards and in
terms of responsibility
it's a it's a topic that's fast
consistency is a topic i've been so
fascinated about over the last year
as i've reflected and done has been sort
of introspective about the things i've
been able to achieve
whether it's getting millions of
followers on social media whether it's
growing my business or
going to the gym it seems that the the
very
ironically consistent theme across all
of them was consistency it was being
able to do
perform x habit for a long period of
time and then you have that
the eighth wonder of the world shows up
and things start compounding in your
favor
very quickly usually um but the other
term that i've been fascinated with
is responsibility and as i've
i started out as an 18 year old kid
dropped out of university
disowned by my parents no money at all
and
the one of the things that i noticed as
i look back on 18 year old steve
versus a lot of other people that i see
that that are living in the same
[ __ ] area i was living in and
stealing pizzas like i was stealing them
um was they don't take responsibility
for their situation
they kind of see themselves as a a
victim of the situation they're in
whereas when i was in that situation not
only did i not view it as my destination
i was literally taking photos of the the
nothingness in my fridge
and the how dire my life was because in
my mind and i
started keeping this diary on facebook
which i really randomly
wrote in my diary that a tv company had
asked me to keep this
because i didn't actually know how to
tell my own diary right that i thought i
was gonna
show the world this someday um i
i didn't see it as my destination and i
took full responsibility of my
circumstance it wasn't anyone's fault
but my own and i was gonna change it
but then one of the things that makes me
concerned um about our generation and
about
certain political narratives and certain
themes i see on the internet
is like a an avoidance of responsibility
for your life and the the default to
blame someone else
and i'll be honest it's something i see
more in the western world than i do
in the african village i was born in
yeah you know so
i wanted to know if really from you like
what role responsibility plays in
people's outcomes
okay that's a big one yeah um
you promised me some easy questions um
no
so um responsibility is huge it's just
massive it's um
it's it's one of the pre it's one of the
predetermined
of successful outcomes is our ability to
take ownership and accountability so
circumstance and situation push and pull
us in different directions on a daily
basis the world is complex it's
uncertain it's unpredictable
all of those things the people who
perform best have huge levels of
responsibility
and ability to respond to those
circumstances and situation no matter
what they are
to drive the best outcomes or
opportunities so i always said there's a
circle of concern
water cooler conversations the stuff
that's going on you know around us
circumstance situation incidents and
accidents
then there's a circle of influence and
the circle of influence is where we make
choice that's what it's about
so responsibility is all about choice
for me i
absolutely guarantee you now that the
circumstance the situation is not a
predictor of success
and um because we know of people who
were born into privilege
their great role models had good access
to opportunity to wealth
they had good guidance and good support
and they ended up dying
heroin addicts in prison we know some
people born with a physical disadvantage
now a lack of good role models now the
lack of guidance lack of support lack of
opportunity
they grew up to be some of the most
successful people who have ever walked
this earth
so it proves beyond doubt that attitude
is more important than intelligence or
facts
and i genuinely believe that to be true
in all areas of high performance that
attitude is more important than
intelligence or facts
i always say give me i will over iq any
one of my teams i'd rather if i will
over iq because high technical expertise
and talk about the western world at the
moment high technical expertise is no
longer as valuable as it used to be
and the reason why high technical
expertise is no longer as valuable as it
used to be
it's because we can google things that's
why so knowing a lot
isn't where your success is going to
come from yeah it's not what you know
which is important
it's how you think about what you know
and how you bring it to life with your
character and personality
to determine the best outcomes or
opportunities
so you know i genuinely believe that the
only way in which
businesses or people will become
successful and truly perform to their
optimum
is taking full accountability and
ownership we need to almost move away
from circumstance and situation which is
a distraction
so um the more that we realize that our
success is dependent upon us
and not on situation the better and
because the world is so unpredictable
i need to simply learn to dance on a
shifting carpet
not see the rug being pulled from under
our feet you know life is a game of
continual adjustment
and it doesn't matter what happens it's
how we react and respond to it to
determine those best opportunities or
outcomes
and i think that you know it's funny
because initially i'm working a lot of
businesses
and um on culture on team
um people strategies and the focus on
responsibility has never been higher
mainly because we've been asked to stay
apart people are having to determine
their own work schedules people have to
determine their own working week and um
they're going to have to
take responsibility for driving the best
outcomes and
whilst they're not surrounded by team or
working with directly with a leader
so it's been a greater call for
responsibility i wonder whether
in answer to your question i don't know
the answer to this
um i wonder whether we'll see a better
shift or greater shift towards more
responsibility in the western world
because i agree with you i think that
many of us will see ourselves as a
victim of circumstance and situation
and not necessarily see the beauty in
the chaos because of it
you talk there about the the internet as
well in the power of the internet and
how that's been a bit of a leveler
which is yeah which is a really
wonderful thing i think um
what how important is it do you do you
think when you think about the
successful people you've worked with
to be a sort of self-driven
learner beyond school um
did you see in the specifically in the
sort of upper echelons of like business
the ones that are the people that are
most successful are
proactive sort of self-driven yeah i
think
i think it's true i think that um i've
said that our only
sustainable competitive advantage is to
learn faster and better than your
competitors
so you know and you think about that for
a business you think about that for a
leader you know you think about as a
sportsman it's probably true isn't it
you know our only sort of
sustainable competitive advantage is
just learn faster and better than anyone
else
two powerline lines yeah yeah and i
think that you know and i think that
i think that how can we learn faster and
better
yeah if we're not proactive lifelong
learners
and so you know and i think that you
know learning isn't necessarily about
being
taught um we don't necessarily need
teachers
um it's a strive for greater curiosity
you know i think curiosity is worth
more than creativity at the moment but
it's a strive for greater curiosity it's
a matter of being
massive being open-minded it's a matter
of being um
agile in our thinking so we can deploy
resourced of opportunity as it becomes
visible
um it's about um it's about
self-discovery
so it's about a variety of things which
are based not necessarily upon
traditional learning
but more in a way in which we can open
our mind up to
experimentation and feedback you know
and
understanding ourselves differently and
i think the best
leaders um you know have this ability to
you know reimagine repurpose reinvent
i don't think they're beholden to a
particular or wedded to a particular
mindset
but that's for a lot of people that's
terrifying the thought of
experimentation and being agile and
reinvention
i've seen that in my own business i've
seen over the years i was um
i was known as being the guy that would
walk in i think a lot of
business leaders are walking in the
morning and be like we're going in a
different direction everyone come in
this room we're going to launch this
part of our business and we're going to
take it
we're going to experiment and i i would
often say to our team that
experimentation is like at the heart of
all of our strategy it's like why
especially as a social media company
where our platforms
social media changes every day there's
new updates pushed by facebook and
instagram every day
um so our company slogan was keeping
keeping brands at the forefront of
what's possible
which meant that we had to be agile but
i'd often see people in my organization
that were
really against change fearful of it
they would take you know they would
resist it
yeah you know uh and i i i am
i wonder how you if it's i always
wondered why it was i think some of them
had
levels of imposter syndrome so they were
you know
they were just uh just trying to get a
hang of the role they were in and not do
more that
you know they were already you know but
i wonder what your thoughts were on that
i think i think people don't like change
because they don't know what it results
in
and that's one of the things so let's
take um
let's take uh moving your desk yeah
someone sat at our desk for ten years in
a particular office he said you know
what you need to you need to move down
the corridor
i'm going to make a move but uh people
weren't like the slightest
um if you said to them that you know you
need to move down the corridor you know
we really appreciate the move we're
going to give you a million pounds at
the end of the year because of it
they'll be trotting off with their
potted plant in hand i guarantee it
so i think that because people don't
necessarily know what it results in
why should we invest in doing something
different which is uncomfortable because
it goes against our mental tram lines
our habitual thinking
so now you're asking me to compromise my
patterns
and i don't know what for and i know
what's going to result in
um it could be good it could be bad so
therefore i'm not sure i want to go to
the trouble
without investing in this change when i
haven't determined you know the result
of it
as human beings we like patterns um
that's good and it's bad
and um it works in our favor sometimes
sometimes it doesn't
so we like patterns and so we like
consistency
and we compartmentalize and how am i
getting a viewpoint on the world and in
fact if you look at um
the office is a good example the office
is a great example of keeping people in
patterns you've got your phone on your
desk here
your computer there come in at a certain
time working a certain way take your
lunch at a certain time
so we're conditioned to work in a way
which is reflective of the consistency
which takes out variance in business so
you think that
management has been around for about 100
years and the reason why management's
been around for about 100 years
is to reduce variance at time because
then you can guess then you can scale
so businesses got bigger a lot bigger
100 years ago
and um because of the ability to keep
people
habitual so um so because we've become
conditioned to do this
and everything around us keeps us in in
in a pattern that we quite like being in
as soon as we start to move outside of
that there's a level of discomfort
so i guess leaders can allow people to
make change atta and embrace
change um i guess there's a few points
one
it's always best if it's co-authored and
co-created right
um so let's involve people in what that
change looks like
um it's always best if um
we look at our organizations or teams as
a community
instead of as a team or an organization
at the moment communities are
outperforming bureaucracies and
hierarchies when it comes to maximizing
human talent
so let's try and form a community and um
let's co-author and co-create
and and then um let's have a look at um
peer recognition peer coaching peer
challenge
it doesn't need to be a top down thing
done to people it can be something which
can
happen from the inside out you know it's
meaningful when
when something is endorsed by others
that that you know you are
that you feel an affinity with sure what
when you read about the steve jobs of
the world and the elon musk's of the
world they seem to buck
all of the a lot of the trends that you
hear in like management coaching they
seem to be
very authoritarian you know i was
reading about from i was reading steve
elon musk's biography and there's
stories of him just like
calling someone into the office and
saying how much does it cost to do this
they'll say 10 million he'll say do it
for
5 and do it within 30 days and they'll
go away feeling puzzled but they'll get
it done
yeah he has this culture of like
intensity and when you start he says to
the teams that this will be the hardest
you've ever worked in your life
but it'll be the most worthwhile but
it'd be the hardest you've ever worked
and
and i you know and then steve jobs as
well i've heard the stories of how he
was
you know how he built the company at
medlo park and um
he seemed like the antithesis of what
you would read about in a business book
but obviously these are two of the most
successful entrepreneurs
the world has ever you know seen so i
wondered if there's a
i'm trying to appreciate the like
how they've achieved their success by
being so different from what all the
business books say
from all accounts they're you know what
i mean
yeah i mean i think a couple of things i
guess that you know you find what works
for you
um i think what they have on their side
is they have a really big
purpose statement it's a really big
mission so there are lots of companies
with
mission statements but very few on a
mission and i guess that when it comes
back to
um the point i made earlier that passion
been a significant multiplier
of human potential i guess that these
people have the ability to engage people
so to tell a story attempt to inspire
and motivate
so i guess that you know there is a
there's no doubt lots of logic
and time there is no doubt lots of
rationality which is used in their
management leadership style
you know but what you're describing to
me in the people that you're describing
i think you can really get behind
something that someone passionately
believes in
and is something which is worthwhile and
purposeful
yeah on such a grand scale so i think
when they're talking about
um and things which will change humanity
um i think it's possible for
you know us to be swept along at him on
that particular vision and
so maybe it does mobilize people in a
different manner because of who they are
what they believe in and what they're
trying to achieve yeah no that's
probably true i mean yeah you think
about i
mean the example i'll give you is jfk
well yeah i mean i mean jfk do you think
that jfk's speech about putting man on
the moon
you should read it actually rather than
look at it um
it's a rubbish speech when you read it
the term and the reason
and the reason why is that there's no
logic to it until there's no rationality
so he says we put a man on the moon and
the reason why he gives that
we should put a man on the moon is
because it's it's hard and not easy
which is a rubbish reason to do anything
it's hard
that's why we're gonna do it yeah so um
but not only did
they end up doing this it mobilized the
whole nation
behind the space race and the whole
nation behind science in fact
um the reason why was that because logic
was low
inspiration was high it was such a
um it was such a literally a moonshot it
was literally such a big goal
and so ambitious so expansive you know
that people bought into the dream
and i wonder whether and i don't know
you know
the examples you gave at steve jobs and
elon musk whether whether people just
buy into that dream and they buy into
what they not necessarily what they're
seeking to do but what they're seeking
to create
and maybe there's a lesson for all of us
who manage and manage teams that
maybe it's not about trying to you know
get people to do stuff it's about people
to
you know to create stuff is that you
know my time to be
part of something which is worthwhile
and meaningful and
sell a big vision and tell the right
story
and you know engage people emotionally
you know all of this stuff about
psychology i know a lot of stuff
i read a few books yeah you've read a
few books about a few books a week last
tuesday
yeah you know don't tell my clients
um you know when people
come across people like you they think
that you've got all the answers and
because you've got all the answers or at
least an answer to most things
um they think that you must live
a life of sort of perfect
decision-making
couples children have the worst worn
shoes yeah exactly
um so yeah what what do you like at
living these things that you're aware of
speaking of performance one of the
things that's integral to performing at
the highest level is nutrition it's
something that i
i guess i took a a long time to finally
believe
but that is why having hewlett's
response for this podcast is such a
privilege because
there was a time in my life especially
when i was early in my business career
where i wasn't getting the vitamins the
minerals and i wasn't having a sort of
nutritionally complete diet i was
if you look at some of my old photos i
was definitely lacking protein as well
and a lot of that maybe it was an excuse
was because
i was um i was busy and
when i discovered huel when a guy called
mike walked past me in the office
wearing a heel t-shirt and shaking a
little bottle and
you know upon my curiosity of asking
what was in that and why he was drinking
it
it really really did change my life and
so here's what i want to do
you know this particular podcast today
has been about high performance and
mindset and how we
how we become our best selves and how we
teach our teams to become our best
selves
i'm going to give away this week five
boxes of your big boxes right
all you've got to do if you want one of
those boxes is hit the subscribe button
on this podcast wherever you're
listening whether you're on youtube
or whether you're on the the podcast or
wherever you might be and leave
a review if you leave a review on the
podcast or just keep your instagram
handle or your twitter handle in there
so i can find you
but if you're listening on youtube then
please um just leave a comment down
below
and any comment you leave enters you
into the competition
and i want to know what you think of
huel so um it's as i say i say it with
full honesty it's changed my life and i
really believe that those of you who
aren't getting your sort of
um all your minerals and proteins and
all the good stuff i think it can change
yours too
what do you like at living these things
that you're aware of
yeah i'm rubbish next question
and the reason why is that two things
that one um
we're all human because we're all human
you know we're all
prone to make mistakes in our doing and
our thinking
um and i think that being you know
better never stops
so therefore we've got to continually
adjust you know we don't
find hints tips gimmicks that make us
better
and then we just apply them regularly
and it works
so i guess there's a level of
inconsistency
which is reflective of the fact that you
know that
i'm a human being who tries to do better
you know give me an exam on a regular
basis
on an example well you're aware of the
truth but you're just
not oh you might you know on the amount
of time so as you know i've been a
guest speaker for 10 years now so when
the world is normal and sane
you know i would um go off four days a
week
anywhere in the world so twice a week i
was abroad
and i'd speak to a few hundred people
i'd stand on stage i'd do an hour's talk
about
performance psychology and i'd come off
um
so i did that for ten years four times a
week and um but
um but i'd often come off and think
cause any good i say to the stake at
stake i would come up to me and say that
you know
that was really brilliant this is
exactly what we're after it's perfect
are you happy
oh yeah it's exactly what we're after
but you sort of covered the brief yeah
yes yeah absolutely it's exactly what it
was
send me an email let me know the
feedback and then
you get you know maybe even get some
feedback which is like you know you get
sort of scored out of five
it's almost like 97 percent five and um
i'd be scouring for the threes and twos
and think that you know there's like you
know 500 people there's that sort of
five people who put two
and so it was all right i just think
[ __ ]
but um but uh but i'd be wondering why
what did i do wrong what was real and
it's
unbelievable it's unbelievable the
amount of times i've sat in front of an
audience
and um and you know maybe 300 people
there there's someone with their arms
folded like that
and they're just like i think he doesn't
look engaged
you know and so out of friend of people
there's something there's most people
writing down things or nodding or
smiling or whatever it is
it's amazing how many times i can pick
out the one person who doesn't seem to
be enjoying
it so i think i think look i think it's
a couple of things
that i'm i'm always prone to you know we
actually
we wait quite highly stuff which we
think we're not doing well
you know we're trying to fix what's not
right about us what's not good you know
you know what we should have done and um
what we could be doing um i think i'm
still prone to that
rather than sort of enjoying the you
know the success that i've had really
what about things in your personal life
in terms of like
like you know health and like being a
parent
and like yeah pursuing goals and
ambitions you have in your personal life
what about those things
yeah i think that you know um
health-wise i need to take some advice
from you
we should i'll lie down and tell you all
about it i keep i keep meaning to
i keep meaning to run more and get to
the gym more there's always an excuse
um so you know i'm the most demotivated
motivational spooky
life's pretty [ __ ] and um so um
so yeah so i think i need to work out
more um i'll tell you the one thing that
gets me
and um i've got three children i got
sort of um four four-year-old twin girls
and a nine-year-old boy um is that you
know as a psychologist
and um yeah i'm pretty good at i've sat
in front of some sort of pretty
difficult clients
some really difficult clients you know
some people at the absolute top of their
profession
and um and they're they're [ __ ]
screwed in their thinking
and um and you know and you know i've
dealt with it
four-year-olds and nine-year-olds just
do me i can't you know i just
you try and apply psychology to it it
doesn't work so the level of frustration
that comes about in regard to being a
parent again this is my point that you
know all human beings
and um so um so you know you try
you try all the influence persuasion and
negotiation
and all the psychology and all the
techniques that you know that um it
doesn't work on four-year-olds
it doesn't work it's so funny the guest
that was here yesterday joe wicks are
the exact same thing he said i'm like a
you know calm guy but he just said you
know
when i my daughter i'll tell her that i
want to just put her down so i can clean
the counter and she just won't be
the irrationality of it is what it does
yeah and um so
you know you know it's funny because um
i've had some really good sports people
sit in front of me and say
you know give me you know you've got
something that makes me better then
and then you give them something and
they go away they come back a week later
and they say i tried that it doesn't
work have you got anything else it's a
bit like going to the gym
working out for half an hour going home
looking in the mirror and says yo let's
crap that
i don't like the gym film refrigerator
um and so
and this is my point that that you know
it's not about tools gimmicks and hints
it's about striving every day to be
better than what you were yesterday
um i worked with a golfer it was very
very good
really good um and you know literally
top 10 in the world
it's about a whole year and uh with just
a piece of paper in his pocket
and he used to play with his piece of
paper in his pocket um and it used to
just say
um what did i enjoy today and what did i
learn today
2 questions on it and then in the
evening he just answered those questions
so that whole year forget the numbers
i'm not going to look at numbers i'm
just going to answer this question
so i've had a good day i've had a bad
day doesn't make any difference i'll
just answer that question
these questions what did i enjoy today
and what did i learn today had the best
year we ever had and i'm just answering
those questions
yeah and in a way there almost needs to
be more simplicity to not using tools
and techniques not to try and apply
psychology to a four-year-old you know
but to just try and consistently enjoy
and learn on a daily basis
so i guess in regard to like you know
yeah i'm still prone to say
god i need to get running okay i've been
drinking all week i need to do some
exercise at the weekend
um and you know again it's falling into
the trap of the
i've been at the mercy of the shoulds
and musks rather than
thinking about at um you know what am i
enjoying what am i learning
what surprised me this week um
you know where am i experimenting and
what have i discovered you know this
week about myself and then once we start
to talk like that
maybe we can so i guess apply more
consistent thinking
and therefore change our doing so you
want to run let's use that as an example
yeah i need to run more definitely i
need to run more why do you need to run
more
and um do you know because i want to
improve my heart and lung health i think
i think i've got tonight it's all right
for you because you're young and fit and
um
but um but i think i've got to an age
now where i realized there's more of an
importance on
exercise so you know before i could just
i'll just do it anyway you know
pick up running every now and then i'll
be able to run i go to the gym every now
and then i'll
have a great time at the gym for a
couple of weeks and then i'll skip it
um yeah but now you know but now it's
it's different a term you know now i
sort of feel
at them as though you know i could be
fitter it should be i think this year
has also
sort of illuminated that for everybody
at the importance of health i think
it's made us all well it has for me made
me think about my health a lot more
no not for the vain reasons that you
know young guy would think about their
health because they're trying to
trying to get laid or something but
because you know i i want to live longer
and i want to have more memories than
those kind of things
did you know near ielts he wrote a book
called indistractible i know yeah i'm
not familiar with i've read it
you're probably familiar with the book
yeah i know the name but i am yeah he
said this quote to me which really
changed my life and i think about it all
the time okay when i find myself
procrastinating from doing something or
whatever he said that typically we think
we're humans that are seeking
pleasure but we're actually living in
the avoidance of discomfort
and when i think about the things that i
procrastinate against or whether you
know we're at six
seven o'clock in the evening you think i
can't be bothered to go whatever it does
ring true to me that i'm actually
avoiding some kind of psychological
discomfort
yes and so i now whenever i feel myself
like this weekend i had
had this big project to do i also had
this talk that i had to do
um for my manager dom and i found myself
like
and then i've got the book my book which
i had to do go through the whole book
from start to finish in a day
and i'm like low-key finding myself oh
just clean the countertop because that's
important
and i said i stopped myself i thought
you're avoiding the discomfort
associated with
sitting down for nine hours until six am
in the morning
and doing the book and it wasn't until i
realized why
you know what i started that term has
been like this flashlight that i shine
in like the corner of the room we're
after hiding the you know the thing that
i don't want to do now
so i wondered if it was you know for
some in in regards to your running
if it's in some respects similar like
you're avoiding some kind of discomfort
where you think
i'd rather play i'm convinced of it
because running such an unpleasant
experience
for me it's a really good example i
can't stand it
so but you're absolutely right that uh
that
you know i totally agree with you that
you know we we do sort of go about our
lives trying to seek
moving out of that space of you know of
of being uncomfortable
this is why we don't have conflict
conversations in the workplace this is
why we don't challenge our own thinking
this is why we don't like change and uh
you know we like we like to operate from
a comfort zone that's what we do
um so yeah no i agree with you i think i
think because running is such an
unpleasant experience for me that's
absolutely awful um i'm probably
avoiding it
because i just don't want the experience
whereas riding a bike
isn't so bad for me um so so yeah so
maybe therefore but
um instead of sat there at four five
o'clock thinking god i need to go
running in an hour
and i really don't want to i'll go
tomorrow
maybe maybe what i should be saying is i
need to go running no you don't um
why don't you ride the bike why didn't
you yeah why don't you just have stairs
um okay well i'll have a go on it after
this
but um we should have done a whole
interview on that i'm gonna kill two
birds with one stone
i hate running as well it's like i hate
the impact on my knees yeah just
i don't want to be outside yeah that'll
be swerving past people so
i got the peloton um it's low resistance
it's
fun super engaging and gamified because
you see the data you see everyone in the
world and where they're placing you see
jenny
55 in north carolina's beating you yeah
make me feel bad
i hate jenny forever that just makes me
realize how unfit i am and how much i
hate other people who are fitter than me
but i mean interestingly it proves how
fit you are because you said you don't
like running because of your knees and
swerving past people
i don't like running because i can't
breathe so you're already winning
chicken egg that'll be cured if you
start running
um but but on that point of um of
psychological discomfort um
how does somebody in your opinion
face a challenge that they know is
uncomfortable like
you know to be honest i don't i don't
want to go to the gym or do all these
zoom calls all the time it's not like
you know i'm not getting comfort or in
pleasure out of doing
two hours zoom calls at the moment about
like you know biotech or whatever it is
the thing that i'm involved in
but i'm doing it and i wanted to know in
your case what what does it take someone
who like doesn't want to do something
because they know it's uncomfortable to
say do you know what [ __ ] it i'm gonna
do it today
yeah and is it does that go back to that
point of of having that like
long anchor purpose yeah i think it does
i mean
mohammed ali said i've i've hated every
moment in the gym but i did it so i
could live the rest of my life
like a champion yeah and it's in in a
way it's true isn't it that
that you know there are there are
component parts
to success um and i think the
two of the interesting one is and the
one that most people probably relate to
is failure
so people don't like to experience
failure but you know for example
failure is part payment towards success
so the price of success
is always paid in full and in advance
the price of success is always paid in
full and in advance you can't be
successful and you start making mistakes
you can't be successful and start having
your two hours zoom calls but uh you
know in a way you
need to fail we need to have these awful
conversations we need to kiss lots of
frogs we need to
you know do deals which don't work but i
mean you do all these things to enable
you to be super successful
so um there's lots of things that um
again it comes back to reframing if we
see it as part and parcel a stepping
stone towards a greater advancement
they're probably more likely to do it
you know if you see failure as something
which is
we're trying to avoid and it's just
awful and you know and it screams to me
that i'm useless
um then we're probably going to stay
within a comfort zone you know
if we embrace failure then we see it as
part payment towards success
until we see it as something which is um
an active contribution a stepping stone
towards
you know being better maybe we're more
likely to indulge in it and not have the
discomfort
that we associate with it so now i feel
that
um it is always good to think about you
know what you think about that end goal
have that purpose that
vision the mission you know what you're
seeking to achieve and create
um and then think about what those
building blocks look like
because you know all great achievements
are the result of many small
achievements
um you know you had joe wicks here
yesterday he wasn't super successful
overnight
and he probably kissed a lot of frogs
i'm sure you talked about it you know
um know his business and korean personal
life went in all sorts of different
directions like ours
at um and you know it's not necessarily
as we said earlier it's not necessarily
what what happens it's
it's our interpretation of what's
happening which will then enable us to
use that as feedback towards something
better
and do you find with a lot of the high
performance people you've worked with
that their childhood is a definitive
reason as to why they are the way they
are today i'm going to try and
articulate this if i can
but i've i from speaking to guests on
this podcast and also from a bit of
introspection to be honest
i tend to think a lot of people that
have
extraordinary outcomes have often had
some kind of extraordinary early
experience and i'll give you a couple of
examples
the a lot of the billionaires that i
know are really really successful people
that i know
um cite their father's disapproval
as the reason why they've always had a
chip on their shoulder and they've
always strived
obsessively to be enough right because
their father told them they weren't
enough
yeah um have you seen that in successful
people that there's the
the thing that makes them just a bit
[ __ ] weird
is often a you know i think one
particular
instance with a friend of mine a comment
their mother made when they were four
that they just can't shake
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean i i'm not a
psychiatrist so i don't delve into
backgrounds in the way that maybe
someone involved in psychiatry would
yes as a performance coach i tend to
work with how people are now
basically and um tell me about what
you're thinking and doing what you're
trying to achieve
and more so than to try and deconstruct
you know or analyze
some of the you know the earlier
experiences um so that's not my thing
having said that though you're
absolutely right there seems to be some
sort of correlation between
extreme experiences and then how people
interpret or translate them
and in fact you know as you're talking i
was trying to think of the book i can't
think of a book i wish i
could now and they talk about in this
book the fact that so many super
successful people
politicians actors um business people
lost parents when they were young and
there's a
direct correlation believe it or not
it's a direct correlation between
people losing parents when they were
young and then becoming super performers
be incredibly successful
um and the psychology behind it was that
you learn independence
and um it's almost easy if you've got
these loving fabulous parents who
you know hopefully you know many people
have got um
you're not as independent you know
whereas you know if you lose a parent
young you
end up sort of doing things for yourself
a little bit earlier
and so maybe that going back to that
responsibility the ownership piece and
i'm having to sort yourself out
and um you know means that people learn
some of the skills which enable their
talent
to then be used differently in the
future but there is a direct correlation
believe it or not i wish i could tell
it's like
the real psychology in the actual
article in the actual piece in the book
um but you just reminded me when you're
talking about it so i do think that some
people do have these extreme experiences
and i think that um it's almost easier
to
get to know ourselves and get to think
about life
and contextualize things um you know if
we're experiencing things which are
outside of our
i guess our normal field of vision i i
resonate a lot with that i um
you said you know lose a parent but the
reason i resonated with that is because
i've said multiple times on this podcast
again
um that when people have asked me why
why i was successful i i cite that when
i was younger my parents weren't ever in
the house
and that made meant that i had to find a
way to make money to feed myself or
you know my mum was never in the house
when i went to bed and she was never
there when i woke up because she was
just
she slept at her shop sometimes my dad
worked in london for six days a week
which was four hours away and i and it
was only
of the four of us in our my family the
four siblings
that wasn't the case for my older
siblings when they were
younger or when they were my age my mom
and dad were in the house every day
doing date nights
together and then when i grew up by the
age of 10 i could leave the house for
three days or two days
and they wouldn't actually know that i'd
gone and so that meant that i became
like this sort of self-autonomous kid at
like
12 13 14 50. and then started businesses
at 14 and then you know
went off but you could have gone the
other way as well couldn't you oh
you know with 100 you know with that
level of freedom and autonomy
but not the maturity and you know to
deal with that freedom
um my friend my best friend said to you
and i'll never forget where i stood when
he said it in this takeaway shop he said
stephen
you're either going to be a criminal or
a millionaire
and it was because i had that my
independence created this connection
where
i knew that my outcomes were going to be
a direct result
of my behavior i always think of like
school dinners as the perfect example
for a lot of my childhood maybe up until
the age of about nine my there was
always like two quid on the counter
which is like okay you take that to
school and then by ten the two quid
wasn't there anymore
yeah so it was like waking up in the
morning and being like how am i gonna
eat today i'd have to find a way so i'd
go and sell cigarettes
or you know i'd like i knew that there
were cigarettes in this this room
upstairs which my mum had got from
nigeria one one year
so i just went to school and i was just
shopping cigarettes or chewing gum and
it was that that connection i made super
early that
my outcomes are a direct and only
correlation of sort of
connected to my behavior um
so i resonate with that a lot and it
kind of explains the difference between
four kids that grew up in the same
household
and one the three of them went to
university llc cambridge whatever and
one of them dropped out of everything
got kicked out of school and became an
entrepreneur
it's true isn't it so it's not
necessarily the um
yeah the experience is how we translate
that experience and exactly how we
channel our feeling into something which
could be productive or destructive
you could have become a criminal and a
millionaire and got a job at this tory
government
you could be
yeah but the last thing i really wanted
to ask you about was um
you know this idea of distractions
social media is uh
made it incredibly easy to distract
ourselves and you see you know teams
becoming
much more distracted at work because of
all these screens and you know the
digitalization of the world and
individuals and
what are what's your thoughts on on why
we're so distracted and how to overcome
it
yeah um it's true that we are distracted
i think focus and concentration
have to be practiced so many things can
be improved
so um whether it's resilience whether
it's concentration
whether it's courage all these things
can be practiced so many think courage
for example i say courage is like a
muscle the more you exercise it the
stronger it gets
so it's possible to exercise all these
things and be better at them
and i think that um it's fine to be
distracted because it's actually quite
nice
to have different stimuli and different
um provocation
and so we just need to choose when it's
good to have that provocation
and change and when we need to
concentrate we need to practice both
now um uh here's the thing for you adam
is that
as human beings we don't multitask so
multitasking is a lie
so for all the um all the girls and all
the women watching this
and um oh listening to this um
i'm sorry to tell you it's not true you
don't multitask better than men
it's true amen it doesn't happen we're
both equally as bad now we're both
useless at it so what we do is we do
rapid switching
so we don't multitask we just want to
talk about exactly um this is why
actually
um i can't remember it was a couple of
years ago that the um
the blackberry network went down in abu
dhabi for a weekend from friday to
monday
had a 48 decrease in car accidents that
we get
really because as human beings we don't
multitask you don't
like check your text and drive well it
doesn't work
so um so i think that we are living in
an age where it's easy to be distracted
and some of these distractions are
incredibly useful um
we need to come back to greater
responsibility and choice
and um let's choose at home you know
when it's fine to do that and
it's fine not to be and um and practice
you know these levels of concentration
of focus that we may need for certain
tasks
but we may not for another so i quite
like
times when i can sit down and read a
book or absorb something or think about
something
and narrow my focus sometimes i quite
like
sort of tv being on music being on at um
phone next to me on the computer because
actually um i'm sometimes picking up on
certain things
which um for a level of creativity can
be quite useful and
a bit of provocation a bit of a bit of
changeability in my thinking because i
get distracted by something and come
back to it
i find that as well i find them for some
bizarre reason if i
if i go for a walk or if i go to the gym
uh inspiration floods into me but when
i'm stood sat in my office
trying to think of stuff it's yeah
almost impossible the shower is another
weird place where my ideas seem to
show up all at once and it's like i'm
not like this isn't hyperbole i'm not
exaggerating at all like if i
if i'm sat here and i'm trying to think
of something to write or whatever yeah
i go for a walk and sometimes i put my
my music in
it's like non-stop and i find that quite
you know
interesting yeah teams are often trying
to think of ideas and creativity and
if you say to people where do you have
your best ideas and have
asked people that question whatever your
best ideas do you know what they'll say
well i'm walking the dog
and when i'm in the shower just about to
fall off the sleep
um on the commute over breakfast uh you
know
um they'll they'll they'll come up with
all some recreational drugs they'll come
up with all sorts of stuff
but no one will ever say in a boardroom
with some mints on the table and a jug
of water
no one will ever say that but but where
do we where do we
um you know try and create ideas in the
business at all we get them around this
boardroom table
no one ever said don't get me wrong you
can't get your team in the shower with
you
maybe you've tried i don't know what
it's like around here maybe you've tried
i don't know yourself
better but um but yeah maybe
yeah maybe we can't do that but we've
got to find a way of trying to
you know uh create a more natural
environment for people to flourish
and i do say to you many organizations i
say to them that you know you're
too quick to train the people rather
than fix the environment
you know people say oh i need more
innovative people they don't um you know
we need to train them on innovation
no you don't let's try and create a
culture an environment where people
are free to express themselves the
problem we've got is that you know we're
so
we're so convergent in our thinking and
uh you know
we start off as divergent thinkers we
start off making really weird
connections
um i had a six-year-old once um asked me
what does the number nine smell like
amazing question i think that's probably
the best question i've ever been asked
well do you respect the interviewer
today i was going to say that but um but
you know what's the number nine smell
like it's a great question
um yeah was the last time you heard a
ceo ask that question they don't
um you know children ask these divergent
questions because they make the
connection between two things
usually unconnected um and then you go
to school and the school says
why are you asking that we're doing
numbers today just concentrate on the
numbers
um and then we go from divergent
thinkers to convergent thinkers
and our careers get better because of it
our businesses get better because of it
and making simple connections you know
margins down okay we need to do this you
know revenue's down okay we need to do
that
um but what do we need in today's
society in today's world
and um i think we need convergent
thinking i think we need to move back
and and get into that divergent space
again
and yeah who are the most successful
people you know at the moment and people
are making really weird connections
people who this is where uber and airbnb
and all these things come from
it's from people who are making a
connection between two things previously
unconnected because they're still
divergent
so let's try and create some
environments where
people are free to explore experiment
free to
break some of the rules and to talk
about things which are
um which are not easily put together and
i think that that's the best way in
which we can
see the opportunity and possibilities in
in this changing world in which we live
in
how do people find you what's the best
uh yeah i think i mean
uh twitter or linkedin really i don't
use anything i don't use facebook or
anything like that so um for your
website
so you're on my website into me people
contact me through my website but i used
uh i started using twitter again and but
linkedin is great for me
i can imagine there are about 30 000
people on linkedin and that's really
where
where i sort of communicate have you um
how do you find social media just out of
interest in terms of life
i'm a bit like an alcoholic who can't
get the top of the bottle
yeah i mean i mean i love the idea of it
but um you know i am you know i i think
oh god i should be doing more
um but um but i but i just don't
people say that you should if it's not
you should you should do yeah well
but you know what it's funny one of the
advices that i give people at the moment
if it ain't broke you should break it
because um you know we almost need to
give up what's allowing us to be
successful
to allow us to be successful and um you
know i know it's a counterintuitive
argument it makes perfect sense to be
honest i mean that's the
definition what innovation is right yeah
it's breaking the blueprint so
so i think that you know and again look
it's probably my running isn't it it's
one of those things which are
uncomfortable so i probably don't do it
so um so what i should do is is
try and find out more about you know
social media and then
i'll have a look at your social channels
after and obviously we've got a lot of
content from this so
we can send it to you in a way that will
do perform well if you post it so listen
thank you for your time
today thank you very very generous and
it's a really inspiring conversation
that's uh
i actually want to read it's one of the
few conversations where i'm like i
really need to re-listen to this again
and maybe with my notepad out and really
take notes because there's so many
ideas that are really really profound at
times that i'm like i'm trying to hold
on to and then
because you're because you're full of
them i'm i'm going back i'm thinking
you know what i mean because there's so
much intelligence condensed in such a
short period of time very kind
no i really mean that as well yeah
sometimes i have experts on that have
really well studied in their field
and the things you say as someone who's
ran a multinational business with 700
employees for the last 10 years of my
life
i'm like perfect sense and i i really
want to i could unpack all of those
individual topics more but yeah
thank you such a pleasure to have you
thank you thank you for inviting me
[Music]